TURNING POINTS U.S.A.'S CANDACE
OWENS WITH THE MOST OF
MINE AS YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD WAS
QUITE EVENTFUL.
AND A MESSAGE FOR WHOOPI
GOLDBERG ON WHAT HAPPENED IN
"THE VIEW" THIS WEEK COMING UP
LATER IN THE SHOW.
EVERY WEEK I DO AN OPENING
STATEMENT ON WHATEVER IT IS THAT
HAS ME FIRED UP.
BARELY ONE, WE ARE GOING UP TO
4.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT, 89
IF DEMOCRATS DON'T GET THEIR YOU
>> DID YOU JUST POINT AT ME?
I DON'T HAVE TRUMP DERANGEMENT.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I HAVE.
I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE STARTING A
CONVERSATION WITH MEXICANS ARE
LIARS AND RAPISTS.
I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE STARTING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS COUNTRY.
I'M 62 YEARS OLD.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN OFFICE I DIDN'T AGREE WITH.
BUT I HAVE NEVER EVER SEEN
ANYBODY LIKE THIS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYBODY WHIP
UP SUCH HATE AND BE SO
DISMISSIVE.
SUFFER FROM THAT.
WAY SUFFER FROM IS THE INABILITY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO FIX THIS.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS YOU TALK
ABOUT A LOT AND I'M CURIOUS BY
THE IS THE DEEP STATE.
HOW LONG HAS THE DEEP STATE BEEN
THERE AND WHO IS RUNNING IT.
>> I WANT TO SCANS YOUR
QUESTION.
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT HOW
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
YOU SAID -- YOU'VE SAID THEY END
THINK ABOUT IT.
JUDGE JEANINE: AFTER THAT IT WAS
CURSED AT AND I AND MY TEAM WERE
I SUPPOSE I SHOULD.
FOR ME, I'M A BIG GIRL AND I
WOULD GO BACK ON "THE VIEW"
AGAIN.
BUT MORE ON THIS ISSUE,
SPECIFICALLY TO WHOOPI WHO I
HAVE KNOWN FOR YEARS.
THERE IS A BIGGER ISSUE OF THAT
PLAY HERE.
"THE VIEW" IS A MICROCOSM OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY.
THE LEVEL OF HATRED TOWARD THE
HAVE SEEN IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
BY POLITICIANS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE, SPORTS FIGURES AND
EVEN THE MEDIA.
THEN HE RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
NOW DONALD TRUMP IS THE TARGET
OF VITRIOL SO PALPABLE IT'S
SIMPLY FRIGHTENING AND REASON
ANYMORE AND THE RIPPLE ITS
NATIONAL IN SCOPE.
FAMILY, FRIEND, ACQUAINTANCES
CAN'T EVEN TALK TO EACH OTHER.
THEY REMOVE EACH OTHER FROM
FACEBOOK AND CHANGE DINNER AND
FAMILY GATHERING PLANS FOR THE
HOLIDAYS DEPENDING ON THEIR
POLITICS.
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A
PUNCH PEOPLE IN THE FACE.
WELL, I WOULD LIKE TO PUNCH HIM
DEBATE THIS GENTLEMAN.
I SAID NO IF I WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL I WOULD TAKE HIM BEHIND
THE GYM AND BEAT THE HELL OUT OF
HIM.
>> WHEN IS THE LAST TIME AN
ACTOR ASSASSINATED A PRESIDENT.
>> YES, I HAVE THOUGHT AN AWFUL
LOT ABOUT BLOWING UP THE WHITE
HOUSE.
JESSE: THAT'S NOT ALL.
WHEN A MEMBER OF CONGRESS CAN
SAY THIS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO WORK
FOR AND SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT WE
HAVE A REAL PROBLEM IN AMERICA.
>> YOU HAVE MEMBERS OF YOUR
CABINET THAT HAVE BEEN THROWN
OUT OF RESTAURANTS.
YOU HAVE PROTESTS AT THEIR
HOUSE.
IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN A RESTAURANT, IN A
DEPARTMENT STORE, AT A GASOLINE
STATION.
YOU GET OUT AND YOU CREATE A
CROWD.
AND YOU TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT
WELCOME ANYMORE ANYWHERE.
JUDGE JEANINE: NOT WELCOME
ANYMORE ANYWHERE.
WHEN WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS NEEDS SECRET
SERVICE PROTECTION BECAUSE SHE
SPEAKS FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, SOMETHING IS
WRONG.
WHEN WE GET SCREAMED AT EVEN
BEFORE WE GIVE AN OPINION,
PEOPLE DOWN, WHEN IT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO NOT HEAR WHAT
PEOPLE THINK, THAT'S THE FIRST
STEP TO WHERE WE DON'T THINK.
THINKING YOU ARE RIGHT AND NOT
OR REPUBLICAN.
OR THE RIGHT OR THE LEFT, IT'S
WRONG.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE SUCCESS
OF OUR NATION.
I LIVED THROUGH 8 YEARS OF
BARACK OBAMA.
A LOT OF YOU HEARD MY OPEN.
I AM VERY CLEAR IN MY OBJECTION
TO HIS POLICIES, BUT I NEVER
ROOTED FOR AMERICA TO FAIL.
THE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD ALL
WANT AND THAT NO ONE WOULD BE
AGAINST SIMPLY DON'T MATTER
ANYMORE.
THE ECONOMY SOARING.
SIGHS  * DEFEATED.
TAX CUTS FOR EVERYONE.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO MATTER IF
IT'S UNDER THIS PRESIDENT.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE BOTTOM HAS TO
FALL OUT AT SOME POINT AND BY
THE WAY I'M HOPING FOR IT.
SORRY IF IT HURTS PEOPLE.
JUDGE JEANINE: FOR ALL YOU ON
THE LEFT ROOTING AGAINST NAIR
YOURSELF IF YOU THINK WHAT YOU
ARE DOING IS STANDING UP FOR
AMERICA.
AND WHEN YOU DO, YOU ARE TEARING
DOWN SOMETHING MORE IMPORTANT
YOU ARE TEARING DOWN THE VALUES
OF THE UNITED STATES ITSELF.
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO SPEAK.
BUT WHEN YOU CAN'T ENLIST ON
WHAT SOMEONE HAS TO SAY BECAUSE
YOU DESPISE THE MAN WHO IS
PRESIDENT, YOU UNDERMINE NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
YOU UNDERMINE THE UNITED STATES.
AND THAT'S MY OPEN.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK ON MY